governor of arkansas mike huckabee who
joins us now governor great to see you
this morning you've heard
all the reports we've been talking about
what's your reaction
well it's pretty troubling to see that
these are children that are being
exploited there are two kinds of people
to come to the united states to
immigrate there are those who come
because they desperately want the
american dream they want to live here
they want freedom they want opportunity
and those are the people that have made
america a wonderful country and thank
god that they have come from all over
the world
to make us a better country and then
there are those who want to exploit the
american dream they want to hurt people
they want to traffic children they want
to abuse them they want to sell drugs
and we have every right and reason to
keep those people out but you can't keep
anybody out and you can't process the
right ones if you don't control the
border and the insanity of the bite
administration's border policy is a
chicken that has come home to roost and
it's time to pluck the chicken and make
sure that we
have control of the borders and control
of the people who truly deserve to come
here and that we want to come here
governor rachel's talked about this and
rightfully so talk to me as a governor
of you know a former governor states are
receiving these people across the
country
families kids how do you absorb into a
community that's over already you know
uh over overworked over taxed uh you
know schools at capacity how do you
absorb this type of illegal activity
the taxpayers spend a whole bunch of
money that they wouldn't be spending
here's what happens when people come
illegally and they come into a situation
they typically are coming in
impoverished
these aren't people who are flying in a
private jet picking up a limo and
driving to a home they just bought which
means that you're going to put them in
your medicaid program
pay all their health care expenses
you're going to put them into your
schools pay all the educational expenses
that's several thousand dollars a year
per child
and it means you're also going to
subsidize food you're going to subsidize
housing and when all this happens who's
paying for that the taxpayers in those
states so i can tell you that every
governor in america any of them that
have their brains still functioning
there's a few that apparently don't but
the rest of them this isn't about
not loving people it's not about being
compassionate it's about not wanting to
put an unfair burden on their already
burdened taxpayers and pushing things
into their budget that they simply can't
afford and here's the other rub the
federal government isn't paying for all
those expenses they're leaving it to the
states to suck it up and pay for it and
that's where the rub comes and so it's
uh it's a huge problem not to mention
that those who come who are being
sexually exploited and trafficked that's
a human tragedy and that tragedy just
keeps on going and going and then when
people bring drugs and they kill
innocent american teenagers uh who pays
for the funeral let me tell you we all
do yeah we all do you know governor
you it and by the way it's happening at
precisely the time that so many people
are struggling to put gas in their tank
and food in the on the table just as you
know this is happening we're seeing the
strain on on the resources this whole
weekend governor we've had this thing
we've decided we're not just going to
report the news we kept asking why why
is this happening why is that happening
why did why did the newspapers suddenly
decide the new york times decided that
they were going to talk about the hunter
biden story let's talk about the why
with this policy because i interviewed
two women who were running for congress
two hispanic women running for congress
on the border they said we're getting
all these hispanic voters american
voters they don't like this they're
turning to republican
candidates because they're not happy
about this if this is so illegally
bad for the democrats why do they keep
doing it
well i could just say because they've
lost their minds because i think they
have that's the obvious reason but i
think they truly believe that they're
going to import people who will vote for
them for the rest of their lives and
they're missing something the people who
will come here who will be responsible
citizens
are coming to be responsible citizens
they want to come and they'll pay taxes
they'll absorb into the communities
they'll open businesses they will help
bring prosperity to the country and
those people when they look around and
say wait a minute i'm working really
hard do i really want all the things
that i'm working for to subsidize the
people who get up at the crack of noon
and maybe don't turn a thing until they
go to their mailbox and pick up their
government check
those folks are going to be republican
not democrat
governor we wanted to take some time
while we have you on the program to talk
about a story that's been talked about
all week long but there's a new angle to
it and it's of course the will smith
chris rock incident and it's the new
angle is denzel washington he said
something earlier that i think we all we
all liked he said something about
this moment and what it means and maybe
the deeper answers he was at a td jake's
leadership summit he said the following
i don't want to say what we talked about
meaning he and will smith but therefore
the grace of god go any of us who are we
to condemn i don't know all of the ins
and outs of the situation but i know the
only solution was prayer there's a
saying when the devil ignores you then
you know you're doing something wrong
the devil goes oh no leave him alone
he's my favorite conversely when the
devil comes at you maybe it's because
he's trying to do something right and
for whatever reason the devil got a hold
of him
that night what we talked about we'd
love to get your perspective on this is
you know not to excuse what will smith
did i don't think anybody's interested
in that or justify it but rather look
forward denzel washington talk about the
only real salvation is prayer
i think one of the things that come out
of this is that it's refreshing to hear
a hollywood star like denzel washington
talk about spiritual things
i love that i appreciate that on this
day that most of us will be going to
church here in a little while how
wonderful it is that somebody from
hollywood actually has the courage to
say i believe in jesus i believe in
forgiveness i believe in grace and
prayer the things that really are the
foundation of america's greatness and
liberty but the thing that i hope people
will understand what will smith did was
reprehensible we all understand that but
will smith is obviously a hurting person
my pastor has said many years
hurt people hurt people in other words
someone who is hurting will end up
hurting other people somewhere will
smith is hurting we can hold him
accountable for what he did and we
should
but what denzel washington was showing
was that even the most reprehensible
person in our midst
somebody needs to be his friend somebody
needs to show him love forgiveness grace
and kindness that's why in america we
provide the worst criminals
among us
with defense attorneys to defend them
and guarantee them the civil rights of a
trial
it makes no sense to some people around
the world but it makes perfect sense to
americans whose basic system is built on
a religious foundation that every
individual matters every person does in
fact count
we hold people accountable for their
crimes but we don't hate them and we
also do not ignore their humanity we
treat them with respect and dignity
whether they deserve it or not that's
exactly what denzel washington was
showing i think it is just something to
celebrate
again
hold will smith accountable for his sins
but i've always found that when someone
is in trouble that's when they really
need a friend and we can act more like
christians then than any other time in
our lives
free sermon appetizer we are all sinners
uh saved only by grace and moments like
this remind us of that we could all be
in the same situation the reminder he's
he's a he's a governor you know former
governor but he was a pastor first
we can tell pastor slash governor those
are the exact words we were hoping here
this morning thank you thank you for
being on fox and friends
thank you